مساء الخير الحديث عن مستقبل سوريا اللي
سال عنه عدد كبير من الاصدقاء يقتضي منا
اولا ان نعرف حاضر سوريا وحاضره الارقام
موسعه اذا اخدنا
الاقتصاد السوري في ارقام نقدر نقول
حضرتكم بايجاز شديد جدا من الاقتصاد
السوري عاده او الحرب اعادته لسنوات طويله
الى الوراء تقديرات البنك الدولي في دراسه
اعداء نهايه 2016 انه خسائر الحرب وتتراوح
من اربعمائه وخمسين الى سبعمائه وثمانين
مليار دولار ازاي هو هذه التكلفه قدرها
وفقا لل سيناريوهين السيناريو الاولاني ان
الحرب تتوقف في عامها السادس 2017
وفي الحاله دي بيكون الخسائر تعادل سبعه
وسته من عشره ضعف الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
لسوريا الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لسوريا في
الفين وعشره كان حوالي تسعه وخمسين مليار
لما ت ضربه في سبعه وسته من عشره يكون
النتيجه حوالي اربعمائه وخمسين مليار
دولار اما اذا [__] طالت الحرب وصلت الى
عامها العاشر
السيناريو اللي احنا رحله قبل ان تكلفه
تبقى حوالي 13 13 في تسعه وخمسين تتكلم
الحدود سبعمائه وثمانين مليار دولار اذا
كان الرقم مش مفهوم بالنسبه لعدد من
حضرتكم تقدر تقول جدا جدا معناها انه
الاقتصاد السوري فقط 13 سنه من عمر يعني
المالي كلما ان تكون السوريين لمده 13 سنه
قد تاخر في صرف بنيه تحتيه دمرت
دمرت وفي مصانع وشركات وبشر قتلوا واه
اراضي احرقت وبالتالي احنا قدام كارثه
اقتصاديه اذا حبينا ناخذ بعض الارقام
ارقام تقول انه مثلا وفقا ايضا الى البنك
الدولي
بارقام 2015 احنا بنتكلم على نسبه فعل
وصلت فقر مدقع اللي هو اقل من دولار
وتسعين سنه التسعه وستين في المائه من
السكان اذا كان معنا نسبه البطاله قفزت من
اقل من عشره في المائه في الفين وعشره الى
اعلن خمسين في المائه بنتكلم على اكثر من
سته وخمسين في المائه من الاعمال المصانع
والشركات ومؤسسات مختلفه ام ا اغلقت
ابوابها او غادرت الى خارج سوريا على
المستوى الاقتصادي و بالارقام لما نتكلم
على المستوى البشري احنا بنتكلم على اه
ارقام من تقديرات اربعمائه الى خمسمائه
الف قتيل على ثلاثه ملايين
يعيشون باعاقات دائمه بنتكلم على نص الشعب
السوري اللي هو واحد وعشرين مليون بتعداد
2009 العدد بنتكلم ان نصف وتم تعبيره اما
تركوا بيوتهم من مدن في سوريا الى مدن
اخرى او تركوها بالكليه وغادره سوريا
تماما بنتكلم على مئات الالاف من الاطفال
اللي فقدوا فرصهم في التعليم المناسب
والرعايه الصحيه وبالتالي فقدوا فرص هم
فيه مستقبل افضل الملك لما بنتكلم عن
العسكريه من سياسيا سوريا ما زالت بلد
معزول حتى هذه اللحظه ويعاني من عقوبات
على من الولايات المتحده ومن اوروبا ومن
الامم المتحده اه منذ 2011 الى الان نتكلم
ايضا على بلد محتل عمليا عسكريا من تركيا
ومن الولايات المتحده وهو تحت الوصايه
الروسيه والايرانيه
على على المستوى الداخلي وبعيدا عن كل
الاطراف الخارجيه السوريه كانت نظام سياسي
كانت نظام سياسي بسيط في العلوم السياسيه
باسمه النظم السياسيه بالنظر الى
الى النظم السياسيه بسيطه او مركبه النظام
السياسي البسيطه
سوريا كان عباره عن حكومه مركزيه وبعد كدا
في اه محليات او المحافظات بتتبع بشكل
مباشر الى النظام المركزي والنظر المركبه
بقي فدرالي او كونفدرالي
سوريا صعبه جدا ترجع نظام سياسي بسيط لانه
على الاقل الكرد اما يتمتع بحكم ذاتي في
مرات يقوم او يصبحوا وتصبح سوريا دوله
فيدراليه من مكون واحد فقط وهو الدوله
السوريه زائد الكرت وبالتالي ابدا زي ما
كان طبعا في السيناريو الاسوء وهو انفصال
الكره ودائم مده سيناريو يعني صعب ان
يتحقق على الاقل في المدى المنظور مش عشان
قوه الدوله السوريه ولكن بسبب تحفظات كل
الاطراف الخارجيه
اذا حبينا نسال السؤال الاهم اللي هو اللي
هو ال السؤال اللي يطرح وكل المهتمين من
حقه ان السوريين او من كلنا المهتمين
بالشان السوري مدى يمكن ان تعود سوريا كما
كانت او كم سنه تحتاج سوريا حتى تعود كما
كانت تعالى ان تنتقص الدراسات الاول
الدوليه بتقول ايه يعني مثلا الامم
المتحده عملت دراسه عملتها منظمه النفط
واللاجئين او عملتها فى 2016
وكانت تقدر كمانه
انه سوري انا اسف عملتها في 2014 على 2014
كان تاجيل القرار او منظمه الامم المتحده
ان ال ال ال سوريا تحتاج الى ثلاثين سنه
حتى دعوه كما كانت بشرط ان تتوقف الحرب
وقتها في هذا العام اللي عملت في الدراسه
وكمان ينمو الاقتصاد بصوره مضطرده بنسبه
خمسه الميه كل سنه في تقديرات ثانيه الضرب
انه تحتاج سوريا الى عشرين سنه الانسان
النقدي اللي عملها اعتقد فيه 2014 و 2015
ايضا ووضع ايضا من معمل المعايير في مراكز
دراسات الطريقه بثلاثين في نسال واربعين
كل منظمه او كل مؤسسه تضع تصور ومعايير
ونسبه النمو تتوقعها والشروط علشان تتحقق
السيناريو الى تامين لكن انا اي من السنه
دي يمكن ان يتحقق اذا كان عشرين سنه
اوثلاثين سنه او اكثر كل السيناريوهات
فتره الحرب تتوقف ثم تبدا عمليه الاعمار
رقم واحد ان الحرب لم تتوقف حتى الان
واحنا في 2019
ومازال المشهور الطويل انه في
خطيره جدا موجوده وهي ادلب ادلب لم تبدا
المعركه بعد ولما تبدا وصفه وام المعارك
لن يكون مبالغه لانها في اكثر من عشره
الاف مسلح اجنبي موجودين في اغلب خلاف
مئات الالاف من اهالي المحافظه وبالتالي
احنا والداني
السيناريو خطير جدا لما ييجوا تعملوا
معاديه ولا يمكن ان يتم الدرك يقول
للجماعات المسلحه اللي موجوده فيها انا
حسمت الحرب ما زالت ممتده فاذا افترضنا
انه مشكله اذن انتهت الحرب كلها وضعت
اوزارها وان
الامريكيه نصف وهناك وانه تم التفاهم مع
الاطراف وكل هذا سوف يحتاج الى سنه
والطويله وانه تم التسويه والتفاهم مع
الكره بحيث انه يكون شيء في صدام مع
النظام يبدا مساله ال اعاده الاعمار
واعاده الاعمار قدمها مشكلتين المشكله
الاولانيه هي التمويل اصدرت الامم المتحده
انه اعاده اعمار تركي
تامر سوريا يحتاج حوالي مائتين وخمسين
مليار دولار النظام بيقول او الحكومه
السوريه نحن نحتاج الى 400 مليار دولار
كان الرقم دقيق في الحالتين لو اخذنا
الرقم الاكثر تحفظا مائتين وخمسين اكيد
الدوله السوريه لا تستطيع ابدا بكل الديون
الضخمه جدا المترتبه عليها وبان اقتصادها
المنهار لا يمكن ابدا ان هي تبدا عمليه
اعمار بمائتين وخمسين مليار دولار يعني
تعادل اه تقريبا خمس اضعاف اقتصادها لما
كانت بكامل عافيتها في الفين وعشره اذا
لازم ما تحتاج الى دون متبرعين او
المساهمين الدول اللي ساهمت في منح طبعا
مش من الحديث مشروطه لازم تحصل في مقابله
على امتيازات او شروط او تبدا في ضخ
استثمارات تعود عليها بالفائده وتنفع
الشعب السوري مشكله اعاده الاعمار او ال
مائتين وخمسين مليار دول ان الدول الراغبه
في اعاده اعمار سوريا غير قادره والدول
القادره غير راغبه مين هي الدول الراغبه
في روسيا وايران وبعض الدول العربيه في
مصر مثلا لكن هذه الدول غير قادره ما
عندهاش الفوز والفلوس اللي تبدا بها اعاده
اعمار بهذا الحجم الهويه ابو الدول
القادره في الدول الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده ودول الخليج الدول غير الراغبه
الفكره ببساطه اي عمليه اعاده اعمار تعني
دعم الرئيس بشار الاسد ونظامه
اللي هم يعارضون
والاخطر انها تعني ايضا دعما غير مباشر
للنظام الايراني اللي هو
وثائق شديده جدا بين وبين النظام السوري
الحالي وبالتالي هذه الدول متردده او غير
راغبه في اعاده الاعمار طيب ممكن الدول
الراغبه تستعين بدوله زي الصين مرحبا
و عندها القدره الصين فعلا مرحبه وتحركت
المليارات من الدولارات في شكل بناء مصادر
واستثمارات لكن الصين تنظر الى سوريا على
انها كامل المنطقه وليس السوريين هل انها
جزء صغير من شبكه كبيره جدا على الكره
الارضيه يخدم مشروعها الضخم اللي هو
الحزام والطريق فيمكن ان يتضخم العراق او
عشرات المليارات لكنها لم تضف مائتين
وخمسين مليار دولار
لنفترض انه كل ده يتحلوا انه المائتين
وخمسين مليار وقلت وبدانا عمليه بناء
للمستشفيات ومصانع ومدارس استمرت على
عشرين اوثلاثين سنه و اه ودي مساله هذا
خطوات اذا
وعشان تتخيل وعمليه الوقت ممكن يكون رقم
واحد ايضا بردو للامم المتحده اللي تاخذ
دراستها جزء من درستها بين على السلطه
الضرر مدينه حلب العظيمه اللي تمت مرحله
الكامل
تحتاج الى ست سنوات مشكله عمرها ولكن ست
سنوات من العمل الكامل ال والمستمر لازاله
الانقاذ فقط الانقاد اللي قدرتها حوالي 15
مليون سنه يمكن ان تحتاج حلب لاعاده القمر
نرجع تاني فلو افترضنا انه بدات عمليات
الاعمار وتوفرت الاموال وبدات عمليات
الاعمار ان يكون قدامنا تحدي ثاني خطير
جدا مسكوت عنه وهو اين الكفاءات والكوادر
البشريه السوريه التي سوف تدرس في المدارس
وتدليل المصانع وتدير الشركات
الازمه الكبيره اللي تواجه سوريا للاسف في
المستقبل المنظور وهو افضل العناصر
السوريه خرجت من سوريا لتشارك في بناء
اقتصاده دول اخرى في اوروبا وفي الدول
العربيه لافضل الكوادر عين الناس اللي
موجودين في سوريا
لكن نتيجه تداعي القدره الاقتصاديه
للمواطن السوري اللي خرج من سوريا من
بدايه الحرب ثم مع اشتعالها كان اما الشخص
اللي عنده القدره الماليه وبالتالي القدره
على الاستثمار
او الشخص اللي هو عنده مهارات ممكن تجعل
وارحب في دول اخرى اذا كان في اوروبا او
في الدول العربيه وبالتالي هذه العناصر هي
الاكبر او ال اكثر قدره على بناء سوريا
هؤلاء الخارج بعضهم قد يعود لكن من الصعب
ان يعود جمعهم خصوصا وان الاوضاع لا تبدو
انها يعني اه روسي او مبشره جدا لعده
سنوات قادمه
التقدير الاقرب للمنطق هو التقديرات اللي
بتقدر ان سوريا تحتاج الى اكثر من ثلاثين
سنه ست وقفت الحرب اليومي يعني مثلا في
تقدير ل اه جهات
عضو في المجلس ال اه الاوروبي للعلاقات
الخارجيه تقديره انه اعاده اعمار سوريا
كما وعودتها الى اه مستويات الفين وعشره
يحتاج من اربعين الى خمسين سنه بدا يتفق
ايضا مع كل تقديرات سنتوقف مع دول البنك
الدولي والامم المتحده اللي انا اشرت
اليها في اه اثناء الحلقه في صحفي ايرلندي
عام الكتاب لطيف اظن اسمه استيفن صار عمل
كتاب شاهد عيان على
الكاس مصير يعرفون
شاهد عيان على الانتفاضه والثوره السوريه
وكان عايش في سوريا السنوات قبل اندلاع
الحرب تقديره نتيجه ال هجره
العقول السوريه والكفاءات السوريه فسوريا
تحتاج الى عشرين سنه اذا توقفت الحرب
اليوم ولكن ليس ل تعود كما كانت الفين
وعشره ولكن لتصبح بنفس مستوى الاوضاع في
اليمن اليوم اتمنى كل الخير وكل
الامنيات الطيبه
لاشقائنا في سوريا واشقائنا في اليمن
واشكركم اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]